una semana difícil para Gustavo Petro el
presidente de Colombia empezó el lunes
con la destitución de tres ministros por
desacuerdos ante la reforma a la salud
que propone y la terminó con un
conflicto en San Vicente del caguán en
el Sureño departamento del caquetá
antiguo bastión de las FARC Campesinos
de la zona llevaban protestando un mes
exigiendo que la petrolera emeral Energy
cumpliese con su promesa de pavimentar
42 kilómetros de vía el jueves escaldó
la situación murieron un líder campesino
y un policía 79 uniformados y seis
trabajadores fueron retenidos hasta ser
liberados el viernes tras la promesa de
Petro de visitar la zona y encontrar una
solución es un gesto
que debe llevar a un replanteamiento de
muchos temas alrededor de el tratamiento
del conflicto social en Colombia también
el viernes se hizo público el informe
anual del alto comisionado para los
derechos humanos en 2022 se registró Un
aumento de la violencia especialmente en
el asesinato de líderes y masacres pero
desde la ONU se muestran esperanzados en
las futuras reformas hemos visto efecto
de la violencia de los grupos armados en
los territorios y por eso llamamos tanto
a la política de desmantelamiento porque
son los grupos armados no estatales y
las organizaciones criminales quienes
están generando tanta violencia en los
territorios
el alto comisionado para la paz de
Colombia destacó el descenso de los
homicidios en enero de 2023 resultados
que Petro relaciona con su proyecto de
paz total con el que busca el fin del
conflicto después de seis décadas este
proceso ha sido otro de sus dolores de
cabeza esta semana el jueves el
presidente pidió a la fiscalía que
investigue a su hijo y a su hermano por
supuestamente haber recibido dinero a
cambio de beneficios presidenciales y
judiciales para paramilitares y
narcotraficantes prácticas de las que
Petro se ha desmarcado